so okay
we we looked in the last segment
at the cognitive dissonance being
experienced by many former and recent
trump supporters because trump stated
the simple fact to candace owens that
vaccines work and they are good and the
people dying of covid disproportionately
are unvaccinated all absolutely true
one of the people triggered by this is
conspiracy theorist alex jones now many
of you emailed me and said david you've
got to cover that alex jones wife was
arrested for domestic violence over the
weekend and uh yes it's hypocritical
that now alex jones says this is private
when
he didn't seem to think that the
specifics of what was going on and the
families of the victims of sandy hook
were private you know i get the
hypocrisy i don't really care about alex
jones personal life what i do care about
is alex jones now completely turning on
donald trump
alex jones after this candace owens
donald trump interview
came in for a so-called emergency
christmas show
in order to
sound the alarm as he sees it about what
donald trump said
suggesting that donald trump might be
ignorant
he might be evil or he might be both
ignorant and evil and saying that trump
lied in his interview with candace owen
so check this out this is really it's
the stuff of dreams these factions
fighting in this way take a look this is
an emergency christmas day warning to
president trump
you are either completely ignorant about
the so-called vaccine gene therapy that
you helped ram through with operation
warp speed
or you're one of the most evil men who
has ever lived
to push
this toxic poison on the public
and to attack your constituents when
they simply try to save their lives and
the lives of others we're about to lay
out the basic incontrovertible facts
that what you told candace owens just a
few days ago
is nothing but a raft of dirty lies so
jones goes on to recite
endless
debunked anti-vaccine lies which i'm not
going to play since i don't want to have
to debunk it piece by piece
but jones does mention that the vaccines
are so-called gene therapies now that's
not true the vaccines don't change your
genes
they don't stay in your body more than a
few days the vaccines are genetically
based therapies they're based on
messenger rna genetic material
the vaccines don't enter the cells of
the nucleus and we could go on but alex
jones is lying and that probably doesn't
surprise you
the most interesting part of this is the
people turning on trump
over something so uncontroversial many
right-wingers will try to soften their
anti-vaccine stances by saying i'm not
against vaccines i'm against mandates
how many times have we heard that
in his interview trump said
people should still have freedom not to
take it
but the vaccines are good and the
vaccines work
and he's still getting crushed so all of
the people saying we're only against the
mandates not the vaccines in the
interview trump said i'm not against i'm
not uh for the mandates i'm just for the
vaccine and they're still going nuts
trump said the vaccines are good and
they work and alex jones is saying this
is evil and these are gene therapies so
were they against the mandates only or
are they actually against the vaccines
it seems pretty clear
as i've said before
the more that these people are fighting
with each other
the less they'll be able to put together
functional 2022 campaigns now my
preference would be
that democrats help themselves in 2022.
it's unclear whether that's going to
happen
so any help that we can get from the
right i will gladly take this also shows
us
that the idea of big tent on the right
is completely bogus if you veer off
script for a day
they come right at you and trump even
tells lies in that clip with candace
owens lies that typically titillate his
followers
but just saying hey the vaccines work
it's mostly unvaccinated people that are
dying it sent a huge portion of his
followers into a tailspin it's hard to
imagine this ends well for them and
that's a good thing it's a sort of
circular firing squad
that is buying more and more ammunition
to use against each other also
consider how trump said nutty things for
four years and these people were calm
he says vaccines work and they go nuts
trump said what if we nuke a hurricane
he drew with a sharpie on a hurricane
map he said what about injecting bleach
you know i could list 30 things
they're
explaining it all away throughout
trump's presidency trump says vaccines
work and suddenly they implode these are
incredible times that we are living in
the hope is
this damages republicans in 2022. we'll
have these clips on our instagram which
you can find at david pakman show make
sure you're following me at david.pakman
as well
one of our sponsors is called privacy
privacy is a totally free service that
i've been using for years privacy lets
me create virtual payment cards with one
click and when i use the virtual card
the money is taken out of my bank
account you can create multiple cards
delete them freeze them set a spending
limit on them let's say i'm signing up
for a free trial and it requires a
credit card privacy will autofill
a virtual card number and then after
signing up i can delete that virtual
card so i know i'm not going to be
charged again something really useful
and very practical or let's say i'm
ordering food over the phone
but i left my wallet somewhere i don't
have my real credit card on me i can use
a virtual card on my privacy mobile app
but really the best part is
you're not out there exposing your real
credit card number so you're not as
susceptible to data breaches and
identity theft privacy is a totally free
service and you'll get five bucks to
spend when you go to privacy dot com
slash pacman the link is right
underneath this video